[Music]
all I want to do is set this in a bigger
context because one of the things were
thinking about here is how we make sense
of our world how we kind away live and
work meaningful youth in it and so you
might ask well you know what what are
the things we're going to try and bring
together and doing this Norma's you
might think well you know the science
has quite a lot to say about this you
might also say there's ethics which is
really about how we try and behave or
live in this world it might be religion
as well and of course you might say well
there's literature this philosophy is
poetry as well so in many ways I'm
asking is there some way in which we can
say these are all important we bring
them together or do we find that we get
friction when we do this do we have to
make decisions about for example well
whether we trust this or that or the
other and even though we decide to try
and bring some things together how are
we able to do this with our kind way
ending up with some kind of mental
compartmentalization is this a real
integration or is it just different bits
of our lives where we function in
different ways now my own background is
I have a scientist who kind of may got
interested in theology but when I was
studying science I think I began to
realize that science was more
complicated than I thought I think I
began by thinking that that science kind
away gave us the most reliable
information about our world we could and
that basically the way science worked
was the way everything ought to work in
other words a scientist in trying to
answer some to a question would think of
doing an experiment but I began to
realize that there are some areas we
just really can't do this for example
questions of right and wrong all these
deeper questions of meaning and so one
of the questions I want to lay out
before you for discussion is this one of
the things I think science is really
good at is helping us to understand how
our world works but I think we need more
than that we to try and understand what
things mean it's not enough to
understand how we work since peak how do
we actually live in this world what do
we mean and I don't Jeanette witness
here at this festival but she wrote a
rather splendid book which as a title
I'm really jealous of why be happy when
you could be
normal I mean I wish I'd written the
book of that title it's just great but
she she makes this point in the book she
says look we are meaning seeking animals
we just can't be content with living and
hunting and recreating that we're
looking for something deeper and in many
ways that's the kind of agenda I'm
beginning to think about this morning
well I'm going to suggest you is that
here's a way of thinking I found helpful
and I kind of we're throwing this at you
in case you find this helpful as well
well as a scientist one things I
discovered is that science develops
different research methods different
ways of in guess to getting our world
depending on the kind of topic that you
want to look at so a physicist might do
it this way
a biologist might do it that way but
they're all doing science it's just that
the area of science means that we use
slightly different ways now some people
have read a biologist called Steven rose
Steven rose written quite a volver
interesting books I'm sure he's spoken
at this festival in the past but here's
something he said I want you to think
about this and see if you think he's
right he says I am convinced of the
ontological unity of our world
but we have to use a methodical
pluralism I said again ontological unity
of our world of reality but
methodologically or ism what did he mean
he says look with just one reality okay
but nevertheless we have to use
different ways different methods try
make sense of it and the question then
is kind of how we bring the outcomes of
these together to get a bigger picture
and I think he's right I've learned a
Heisenberg who I discovered studying I
was doing quantum theory doctor many
years ago said something very very
similar he says we always got to
remember that it's not reality we're
looking at its reality as it is
disclosed by our research methods so
each research method gives you an
angular kind of a way of approaching
something but it doesn't give you the
full picture so for me that kind way is
the issue I'm going to explore with you
this morning
my goal suggests is that in general
maybe there are different ways of
engaging our world active
levels and a research method that works
very well in one area doesn't work so
well in another a good example science
and ethics now science is very very good
at telling us how things work but David
Hume famously said I've yet to see a
rebuttal of this that basically science
cannot make the transition from this is
the way things are - this is the way
things ought to be
in other words science really can help
us think about ethics it can inform our
thinking but never less is not going to
give us answers to questions like what
is right and what is wrong now that's
really interesting as far as I'm
concerned because it raises this
question science isn't able to really
deal with ethical questions so what
happens if you are a scientist and I'm
sure that many here this morning and you
want to think about ethical questions
does the fact that ethics works in one
way and science in another way mean that
science is incompatible with ethics well
no no it just means that use this method
in science use different methods and
ethics but there are scientists as we
all know who are passionately committed
to ethical questions
global warming being a very good example
of that but there are many others as
well so let me try and make this more
interesting by looking at a writer who I
think you'll all have heard of who I
think writes well on these themes this
is Albert Einstein and I first began to
learn with Einstein when I began study
chemistry back in Oxford in 1971 and I
kind of stayed with him ever since
because he's a very interesting writer
and Einstein was convinced that there is
one big picture one way of looking at
things which actually makes sense of our
world but it has different elements ok
so he is as you all know a wonderful
scientist probably the best known
scientist of 20th century and he
deserves two accolades and in many ways
he's someone who has worked hard to help
us understand how science functions but
as many of you will know Einstein was
also very interested in ethics
and very interested in religion so let
me give you a quote from a from a
lecture he gave talking about the
relationship of science religion ethics
here we go this instant from a lecture
of 1939 science he writes cannot create
ends and even less instill them in human
beings at most it can supply the means
by which to attain certain ends and the
point is trying to make here is that
science is great and it may help us
inform our ethical thinking but it
doesn't give us the answers again here's
another quote from that same lecture the
scientific method can teach us nothing
beyond how effects are related to and
conditioned by each other the knowledge
of what is does not open the door
directly to the knowledge of what should
be one may the clearest most complete
knowledge of what is and yet not be able
to deduce from that what should be the
goal of our human aspirations so what
I'm saying is that basic when he comes
to his politics and his ethics science
might help a little bit but really he's
using a different method knife many of
you will know that Einstein was a very
committed socialist and in effect got
his socialist values not from science
but in effect from reflecting on what it
meant to be a human being especially
with the situation of 1930s in Nazi
Germany as many people know Einstein was
German and in effect had to leave
Germany because he was Jewish in 1929
29:33 and settled in United States so
here's my point
Einstein was absolutely convinced you
can be a scientist he was and you can be
a socialist he was and saw these in
effect as being two aspects of his life
two bits of this bigger picture to like
so think about this he's a scientist
allowed to be a socialist or he don't
like socialism is a scientist allowed to
be a political liberal or conservative I
the answer has to be yes because science
doesn't lay down this is a way you've
got to be politically or ethically and
then we move on to the whole area of
religion this to me is really
interesting
Einstein took the view that religion
really is important he was he had his
own view what religion was it he did not
believe in a personal God he believed in
a God who was the mind behind this
universe and science could help you
kinda way know something about this God
and it was really a fundamental
motivation for doing science but he
didn't really like his own judeth Jewish
religion very much or Christianity or
anything actually but he liked this idea
that being something deeply religious
about the way the world was and again
that was part of the way he was and
Einstein for example talks about his
idea what God is like listen to this I
believe in Spinoza's God who reveals
himself in the orderly of harmony of
what exists or again I believe in I have
a firm belief in a superior mind that
reveals itself in the world of
experience for motivates props and
interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at IAI TV
you